I can't imagine not creating things. It's
the most fundamental and uncomplicated joy
that I can imagine.
I had two grandparents who succumed to cancer,
so I'm really passionate about studying the
body, the different processes that facilitate
its physiology.
I love how kids can just smile. They are passionate
about everything that they're involved in,
and they want to learn, and they want to grow,
and they want you to teach them. I love the
life and joy that kids bring.
I am most passionate about my faith. I just
want to live in a way that makes others wonder
who or what I'm living for.
I hope to one day go back to Kenya and contribute
greatly to the field of medical research,
and also provide quality medical care to Kenyan
patients.
A dream of mine has always been to be a scientific illustrator, and Hillsdale has helped me see
how that's attainable by giving me a strong
classical training in art, and instilling
in me how important intellectual curiosity
is.
Whatever I do, whether it be pursuing baseball
or a career in the business world, I just
want to be the man that God wants me to be.
My greatest hope for my life is that I can
be successful as a teacher, and what that
means to me is that I can teach kids what
I've learned here at Hillsdale, which is how
to think and how to question the world around
me, and become the best versions of themselves.